hey guys thanks for tuning in today I'm
going to be reviewing the Microsoft band
too so originally I was going to do this
in an all professional like kind of way
and I've written a script and everything
and done all this footage and then I
thought nah screw it I'm just gonna talk
you through it that was an unintentional
rhyme so it needs a script I can come up
with rhymes on the flies so anyways the
Microsoft band too this is quite clearly
based on name the sequel or the
successor to the Microsoft band one
which at the time was just called the
Microsoft band I was a big fan of
Microsoft band if you see my previous
review then you will already know that I
thought the original band was a really
cool device it had ten separate sensors
which is more than pretty much any of
the other fitness trackers I mean
nothing obscene the different it had the
normal heart rate monitor it had the
usual pedometer add an accelerometer
lots of things ending in emitter and he
used these to collect all the same kind
of data as the others on top of that
though it had a GPS which at the time
wasn't that common I think now you can
also get the tomtom spark that has a GPS
that's one of the most useful things I
find and also had a UV sensor not sure
how useful that is you could use it to
tell whether or not you to put on Sun
cream which is always a big issue for
many of us I'm sure on top of that it
had a few other things a microphone for
Cortana if you didn't have Windows then
you couldn't use katana say 10 census
sounds a lot more press event was but it
was still jam packed with stuff and the
data at gavey was really useful and
interesting and I found it really helped
me to approach my running in particular
in a much more structured way once I
could see my
splits and my best times and my exactly
roots and I was also just really
interesting seeing how its performing in
the gym how that was affecting my
calories burns which days I was walking
the vitamin again this is all stuff you
can do with most fitness trackers but I
just found that the Microsoft band had
an awful lot of information and it
combined it in a really useful and
interesting way and what appealed to me
about my club and initially was that it
combined this with some great
productivity features nothing it wasn't
a smart watch it was definitely finished
track of first but it also had the
ability to receive incoming
notifications and it supported
third-party applications i had a
immediate controller on there i just
feel like the whole package and then the
fact that it could tell you things like
your vo2 max which other ones to my
knowledge don't do was just icing on the
cake so overall i really like the mic
rock band and it was the first fitness
tracker that i wore regularly and really
enjoyed previously I've had a jawbone up
one and that was a bit more than a so
yes in terms of appearance you can
certainly see this as a much more
handsome device befitting my handsome
wrist it's much more curves than the old
one it has a nice curve display similar
to the galaxy gear fit the band itself
is much more flexible rather than the
kind of rigid rocky thing we had before
the only downside is that this clasp is
still rather large it's very good to use
and to easily change the size and the
fit but it's such a big thing that yes
it does still kind of getting the way
when you're typing I'm a writer and I
type about 10,000 words a day so I would
know it does get in my way but I find if
I move it up my arms slightly and if I
kind of hover my wrists which you kind
of Mexico anyways that it's not a
problem for me it's not a deal breaker
so I don't think it would be for you
either and overall it's a lot more
comfortable and one other thing is that
the screen now has this nice gorilla
glass layer which means all those Knicks
and thinks that we had before on
Microsoft band one should no longer be a
problem I've already scraped mine across
the wall in prep and
still looking good as new you're welcome
so yeah in terms of look and
practicality Microsoft has probably
ninety percent succeeded on their gold
really make the clasp a little bit
smaller it would be a comfortable normal
fitness tracker and overall it's
certainly a big improvement and I find I
am wearing it off so that's a good sign
I would like to seen them make it fully
waterproof you still can take it
swimming which is a shame and you're not
supposed to take in the shower is splash
proof water resistant but it's not
completely waterproof which is a shame
for some people it's also the battery
life is still what it was before about
two days and you will find you get less
than that if you use it on a run or
something again not a massive problem
for me most people say they charge it
every morning when they were the shower
because they can't wear it then and
that's fine and for me it's fine as well
but if you are someone who rides to work
right home from work and then go to the
gym you might find that you struggle a
bit with a battery drain and then you
might lose your data which would be a
big shame so unless you're super super
active battery's fine if you are
secretive proactive you aren't what I
ever think about just how much better
you're going to need whether the balance
you can live up to your lofty standards
so in terms of the more interesting
stuff what as Microsoft done to upgrade
the experience in terms of the internals
and the software well actually not all
that much if you compare it to the
Microsoft band one so the UI has got
slightly cleaner look and a couple of
nice animations which were there before
so that's nice also the UV sensor is now
continuous when you're exercising so it
will tell you when you need to put on
suntan lotion value able to take a
reading yes that is what everyone wanted
from the band One what anyways doesn't
matter cool is there great there's also
a barometer which tells you how many
flights of stairs you've ascended during
the day also a little bit odd so I'm
wondering if Microsoft has got
more plans for that it would go to me
like you climb three flights of stairs
today i'll be on the tube or the stairs
outside my house and I'm like cool good
thanks but yes so those are super
exciting one feature that's come along
that is quite interesting is now it has
smart alarm which means like some other
fitness trackers if you set the alarm it
will go up up to half an hour all the
time you set it when you're in the
lighter stage of your sleep and this is
good because it means you have less
sleep inertia you're less groggy in the
morning I had this old feature on the
jawbone up and I find it works better on
the wac softbound often when it wakes me
up I find I'm actually just about
feeling like I'm waking up anyways it's
strange feeling of course I often end up
going back to sleep anyways because my
mom hasn't gone off yet the real one
real well armed that's a yeah I mean
it's useful I don't use it as well as I
should but I think if you did have the
willpower job there but you would feel
better using the smart alarm on there
another really cool feature that's an
update for some people is that if you're
on Android you now have access to the
keyboard for responding to texts so you
get your notifications through here
that's like calls emails SMS even
whatsapp but previously you can only
send a pre-written response if you are
on either Android or iPhone and you have
to be on windows phone in order to
access the cool on-screen keyboard to
type out your responses now even on
Android you can access that keyboard so
I can type a full response if I want to
on my wrist and it works way better than
it has any right to it's actually really
cool I mean I can't see myself doing it
instead of my phone it's not exactly
practical it's still quite slow it's
definitely a cool gimmick to show off to
people and in an emergency you could see
it being actually really quite useful so
that's quite nice I don't know if it
works with iOS but it certainly works
with Android Windows Phone users as
before still get access to Cortana sadly
we don't yet on Android maybe we will do
in the future because they are bringing
Cortana to Android
iOS so watch this space and actually
that's largely in terms of measurable
updates on the Microsoft band once it's
quite a similar device but what's cool
and what a lot of reviews miss out is
the fact that Microsoft has been
continuously updating the software on
the Microsoft band one so that it's
considerably better even if you've still
got a band worn it's much better now
than it was when you got it they did a
golf tile a while back so now on both
the band one answer you can track your
performance when you're playing golf
it's not something I've used and I've
heard it's not amazingly accurate but
that's like a great example of how
Microsoft's are continuously improving
the experience they've also added the
cycle tile that was right near the
beginning so before you have to use the
run toe and your cycling which wasn't
very good for cyclists now you've got a
dedicated cycle tile which is cool you
also have the ability to do guided
workouts on the band one and two so you
can go online you can find a workout
that you want to do and you can set it
up so today I was waiting in from parcel
I couldn't go outside our stuff
inspiration it's quite hard to work out
in my flat so i looked on my wrist and I
found that I could do a lunge to barter
so normally I like to do my aim workouts
because yeah I know I'm doing I like to
have a program in mind but every now and
then I like to mix things up and this
was a bit of fun at something tiffany
talks you through it and you get to see
your heart rate and it knows how hard
you work in and it caused it all it's
great and an update to that that wasn't
there before is now you can create your
own guided workout so if you know what
workout you want to do and you just want
to be prompted on your wrist instead of
looking like a noob walking around with
a piece of paper as a noob not Anubis
that's a really weird egyptology Jake
then you can create their own workout on
the Microsoft health app and then you
can sync it to your phone to your band
and then you can follow it in the gym so
that's something cool it wasn't there
before you can also now delete workouts
or sleeps if the data is wrong but you
can do before and it's just all these
little iterative improvements that
Microsoft and bring into the band to the
to the band and made it better and
better and I imagine they're going to
continue doing that with the band 2 i'm
very interested to see where they go
with it because there's lots of sensors
that aren't
fully utilized at the moment and they're
clearly invested in this so it's great
it's like you don't know what's coming
next it's like free updates your thing
gets better and better after you've
bought it and I'm really excited to see
how this performs in a year's time I'd
love to see something like movement
tracking that would count reps on press
ups for instance but that's probably
something else big that Microsoft added
to the band experience is the ability to
install third-party apps which weren't
there before and they've gradually
improved the amount of access that
developers have to the sensors so now i
have band tasca on my band and that is
basically an app that lets me use tasker
for android on my phone tasca for
android is a phone automation app which
lets you access all kinds of features on
the phone for instance you can set up
your phone so that the Wi-Fi connects
automatically when you get home and the
Wi-Fi turns off when you leave the house
things like that with fantastic oh I can
use that as a controller for my phone so
I have a find my phone feature which
turns up the volume and vibrates Alex
noise need to find the phone i also have
a call hannah tile now which lets me
call my wife just tap i have the ability
to turn off the phone and i can take a
photo remotely safe little posed for a
photo and a group i don't have to go and
hit the timer i can just close the
shutter on my band like these things are
really cool like i said there's also a
media controller so i can control my
music what's the month ago and again
it's interesting what developers are
going to bring to it in the future and
i've got a few ideas that I've been
meaning to work on for a while there's
also the ability to much more easily if
you don't have any coding skill set up
the tile for an RSS feed which mites
often made very easy say whatever weird
hobby you're into you can have now
updating on your wrist for you which is
cool as well overall then the microsoft
found two still isn't perfect it's
definitely an improvement on the
Microsoft band one and it's definitely a
very cool fitness tracker and a fairly
useful productivity device as well as it
lets you keep your head out of your
phone and keep you more present on
what's going on around you overall I
really like it I think it's a great step
in the right direction they wish they
brought a few more sensors perhaps made
it waterproof would have been really
nice but again I'm really interesting
how they continue to develop it and if
they show the same interests they have
over the last year then I think it's got
great potential so if you're looking for
a fitness tracker then this is a great
one I'm going to be talking a little bit
more in future in articles and also on
this channel about how useful fitness
trackers are in general and also how you
can track your fitness without a fitness
tracker and what some of the interesting
future trackers are that can do all
kinds of different things and whether or
not they're any good so if you're
interested in the topic and fitness
tracking in general is it useful that's
a whole different question but if you
want a flint striker this is a good one
and I'm really enjoying using it so yeah
few notes that stuff from being perfect
but gets a thumbs up from me so thanks
for watching and I'll catch you next
time bye for now
you